foreign
[Music]
I'm an instructor at the Channing
division of network medicine at Brigham
and Women's Hospital and Harvard Medical
School and today I'd like to talk about
developing disease insights with
genotype-specific regulatory networks
and to begin I thought it'd be useful to
recap
what we've learned from over a decade of
genome-wide Association studies
and I think one of the most striking
results is the effect size distribution
of these geost variants so if you look
here at the figure that I'm displaying
from a paper by Molly Hall and
colleagues they took variants from The
genome catalog the GEOS catalog and they
plotted them by their effect size and
what you can see here for the odds ratio
is that the overwhelming majority of
these variants lie within an effect size
range of 1.1 to 1.4
and this is pretty small especially if
you compare this to some of the
mendelian or rare disease variants that
have been found in the past and to sort
of further complicate matters they
overwhelmingly lie in non-coding regions
so they don't affect protein sequence as
far as We Know
and as a follow-up to this they also
seem to be more likely to be associated
with changes in expression of nearby
genes so what I'm showing you here is a
figure from Evan Boyle and colleagues
from a cell paper in 2017 where they
took data from a genome-wide Association
study of height and they're plotting
here the p-values for all of the Snips
that were tested in this gewa study
and the black curve that you're looking
at is the p-value distribution for all
Snips and then the colored curves are
the p-value distributions for Snips that
have additional sort of functional
information for example we have
h3k27 trimethylation which is in blue
that's a repressive Mark and you can see
that the distribution is not any more
inflated than the genome-wide
distribution of p-values however you
start to see an enrichment for these uh
genome-wide associations for height when
you look at more active marks like h3k27
acetylation in orange or eqtls which are
the most enriched shown here in Red so
taken together what this suggests is
that variants that are associated with
diseases in human traits tend to have
small effect sizes they lie in
non-coding regions and they're
associated with changes in expression
and in that same paper by uh Evan Boyle
and colleagues they found that Heritage
ability explained by Snips in broadly
active regulatory regions is roughly
equivalent to that explained by Snips in
cell type specific regions as well so
not only are they small and non-coding
and Regulatory they're also spread out
throughout the genome and they don't
seem to be especially cell type specific
or that rather that they're balanced
with broadly active regulatory regions
so this begs the question then
how can we build interpretable models
that integrate these many regulatory
variants if we have lots of them they're
all of weak effect then we need a way to
try to pull them all together
and one way to think about this is to
ask which regulatory processes are
strongly influenced by Snips so we know
that for example variants that are eqtls
those are enriched for genome-wide
Association signals and there was a
paper that came out recently from alcus
Price's lab where they wanted to look at
the annotations related to transcription
Factor binding and so they used a model
that they developed called LD score
regression and what they did is looked
at how much of the heritability can be
explained for a variety of diseases by
using knowledge of transcription Factor
binding sites in a cell type specific
Manner and what they find is that TF
binding annotations explain substantial
disease heritability and can help refine
genome-wide Association signals so this
suggests that an important regulatory
process that is related to disease
heritability is transcription Factor
regulation
so how can we connect then these many
CIS regulatory elements these different
transcription Factor binding sites
throughout the genome in a coherent way
and what I'd like to talk to you about
today is a gene regulatory approach for
doing that and so here I'm going to give
you sort of a toy example to illustrate
what I mean by Gene regulatory Network
as that can mean different things to
different people so here I'm talking
about a transcription Factor Gene
regulatory Network and you can see here
I have three transcription factors a
blue a green and a red one
and the blue one for example might go
and bind to the promoter sequence of
Gene 2. and if that is sufficient then
it will initiate transcription of Gene 2
resulting in the production of mRNA for
that Gene however there's often
combinatorial regulation that occurs as
well so for example the green TF and the
blue TF might actually dimerize or form
a complex and then once that has
occurred they go on and they bind
together to Gene 3 resulting perhaps in
its transcription
in addition you can have binding of
different transcription factors in the
promoter region where they're not
necessarily physically interacting but
they co-regulate genes uh based on their
sequence motifs so this whole process
that I've described you can represent as
a network so for example for
transcription Factor one the blue
transcription Factor you would draw an
edge from it to the genes that it binds
to in this case that's Gene 2 and Gene 3
and then you would repeat this for the
green one you would draw an edge from
transcription Factor 2 to Gene 1 and
Gene 3 and the same for transcription
factor three so you can do this for all
transcription factors to all genes where
they bind and build up a network of
edges
one important thing to realize though is
that these edges are dependent on the
cell's environment and state so not only
are transcription factors for example on
and off in different cell types but the
regulatory wiring changes between cell
types and between cell States so for
example you might have a cardiomyocyte
cell that has one transcription Factor
wiring diagram and you might have an LCL
that has a different one even though you
have broadly speaking the same
transcription factors and genes that are
involved and it's this change of wiring
that we found is very important for
talking about cell phenotypes and is
related to different diseases
so here today what I'd like to do is
talk to you about our recent method for
integrating Snips into these Gene
regulatory networks and the method that
we developed is called egrit estimating
the genetic regulatory effects on TFS
and it's based on a simple premise the
idea is that Snips that disrupt proximal
transcription Factor binding and our
eqtls for a proximal Gene should alter
that TF to Gene Edge weight
in addition these Edge weights from
transcription factors to genes should be
genotype specific so if you have an
individual and they have a copy of the
variant that is disrupting the TF to
Gene Edge then you would like to update
the edge weight but if they don't carry
the variant The Edge weight should
remain the same
in addition these Edge weights should
reflect what we know about transcription
Factor regulation for example we know
that genes are regulated by
combinatorial configurations of
transcription factors we also know that
coexpress genes are likely to be
targeted by similar transcription
factors
so what we'd like to do then is take all
of this and operationalize it and so
what we do in Egret is first we build
what we call a genotype aware prior
Network
so what you start with is a
transcription Factor Motif prior so here
what we do is take the sequence motifs
for a transcription Factor so those are
the the genetics the sort of eight base
pair for example genetic sequences that
we know transcription factors bind to
and then for a given transcription
factor and its TF sequence Motif we scan
the promoter regions of all the genes
and ask whether or not that sequence
Motif appears in the promoter region of
the gene if it does then we draw an edge
from the transcription factor to the
gene we then repeat this for each
transcription Factor scanning all genes
in the genome
there are roughly six to seven hundred
transcription factors that have sequence
motifs that we can use and so you repeat
that and you build up a prior Network an
initial guess of where we think
transcription factors bind and regulate
genes then to build the genotype
specificity we take an individual's
genotype and we ask whether or not they
possess any variance within the
transcription Factor motifs that we
identified in that previous step
for those that do exist in the motif we
then use a tool called cubic developed
by reluca Gordon's Lab at Duke and we to
ask whether or not that variant present
in the motif affects the transcription
Factor binding and cubic uses a mix of
protein binding microarrays in linear
modeling to give you an estimate of
whether or not it thinks that variant is
disrupting The Binding of that motif
then finally to include some regulatory
information we ask whether or not the
variant that is present in the motif and
in this case has a cubic effect
suggesting it's disrupting binding we
then ask whether or not that that
variant or snip is in eqtl for the
proximal Gene
if it is we include it and we use the
effect size from the eqtl so the beta
value and add that in as well
all together we then generate what we
call an e-grip prior Network which is
really a re-weighted version of this
Motif prior so what we've done is we've
re-weighted edges based on the genotype
information cubic effect sizes and the
qtls to then get an individual specific
prior Network
we don't want to stop there though we'd
like to integrate what we know about
gene expression regulation by
transcription factors more generally and
so we use a tool called Panda which is
developed using a message passing
approach to add in additional
information so here what you're looking
at is again a transcription factor to
Gene Network and I've colored these
prior Edge weights in Gray and you can
see that they're varying thicknesses
suggesting the different Edge weights
here
and what we want to do next is actually
include gene co-expression or
correlation information to update these
Edge weights so for example if I have
these four genes I have two in yellow
and two in brown and you can see from
the expression profiles here that my two
yellow genes seem to be correlated in
their expression across samples
and the two brown genes also seem to be
correlated in their expression across
samples and so what I'd like to do is
ask well if these genes are correlated
are they also being targeted by the same
transcription factors so for example
with this dark green transcription
Factor on the left or on the right here
you can see I've highlighted its two
edges that go to the brown genes with
these red arrows suggesting that this TF
is regulating both of those genes and
those genes are correlated in their
expression that suggests that I think
these these prior Edge weights in Gray
should be up weighted because there's
additional information suggesting that
this regulation is occurring
next we want to also look at
transcription Factor transcription
Factor co-regulation so we look at this
in the form of tftf protein interactions
and we take for example the string
database and look at all transcription
factors that have interaction
information and we highlight those so
I've drawn an arc between for example
the the medium green and dark green tree
TFS here at the top and what I want to
do then is ask whether or not they're
targeting similar sets of genes so this
other pair of arrows that I have here
you can see that this medium brown Gene
here is being targeted by both of the
transcription factors that have a
protein protein interaction
this means that I want to upweight these
gray edges that are that are impinging
on this like brown Gene because I know
that the both the transcription factors
which I know regulate which should
regulate the same thing because they
bind together that is additional
information that these should be
upweighted edges
so what we do then is repeat this
process that I've described to you using
this message passing approach we iterate
consecutively until we get a convergence
and then we get as an output Edge weight
estimates for all transcription Factor
Gene pairs for an individual and that's
what we call an e-grid Network so we
have Edge weights from TFS to genes and
these prior Edge weights have now been
updated to include this additional
information about regulation however we
still have at the end a unique set of
edge weights for each individual based
on their genotype and they'll of course
share many Edge weights with the same
value because not all variants are going
not everyone shares the same set of
variants of course and and some edges
will not be affected by this but what we
get then is an ensemble of networks and
Edge weights that we can use
an important next question of course is
whether or not all this data integration
is worthwhile so does it improve
performance and here when I refer to
Performance what I mean is predicting
transcription Factor binding using chip
seek information in this case collected
from the remap 2 database so what we did
is we looked at the percent Improvement
in the area under the receiver rate the
receiver operating curve
and we looked at various combinations of
data input for example if you just use
the cubic binding effect and the dosage
effectively how many copies of a snip in
individual carries you don't see much
improvement in binding prediction
if you just use the eqtl effect size
alone you also don't see any Improvement
if you use the dosage plus the eqtl
effect size you do see some improvement
however if you use the binding effect
from cubic the eqtl effect size and the
dosage altogether you see a much more
substantial boost in performance and to
give you a sort of sense of what this
disrupted binding and disrupted Edge
weight might look like we reconstructed
Egret networks in k562 and gm12878 cell
lines
and
focused on was one of the top disrupted
edges in k562 which is between the
transcription Factor Rel a and the gene
slc1689
here you're looking at the tracks for
the different data related to this Edge
so the purple track in the top here is
the eqtl variant that lies in the relay
Motif and is an eqtl for the gene
slc16a9
the gold tracks are the genotype tracks
for gm12878 in the top k562 in the
bottom
and what you can see is that k562 has
the variant that's associated with the
change in Express with the expression
the eqtl variant that we have in the
purple at the top that lies in the
relatf motif
if you then look at The Binding in teal
what you can see is that this is Chip
seek binding there's no chip seek
binding for Rel a and k562 in this site
however there is binding for relay in
gm12878 suggesting that the presence of
this variant in k562 is resulting in
changes in chip seek binding as a result
so we have this Edge weight disruption
in k562 but not in gm12878
so next what we'd like to do of course
is kind of operationalize Egret in a way
that we can use it for estimating uh
networks in a population and so what we
did is we took data from Nick banovich
and colleagues
an estimated genotype and cell type
specific networks for 119 individuals
using this data and in particular they
collected human induced pluripotent stem
cell data lcl's and cardiomyocytes
induced from the ipses and generated
rna-seq for each of the cell types and
they collected genotypes as well they
also performed eqtl analysis and so we
took all of this data
and what we wanted to do was build Egret
networks for these 119 individuals in
the three cell types so for each
individual we get three different
networks for each of the cell types and
then we repeat this 119 times
in addition
what we wanted to do as a comparison was
generate a network as a baseline that
included no genotype specific
information so for each of these three
cell types what we did is we took the
cell type specific gene expression the
tftf interaction data which is from a
string database which is cell type
independent and we use the TF Motif
scans that we have which are also cell
type independent and we integrated those
using Egret but without any genotype
information so that gives us a set of TF
to Gene Edge weights that don't know
anything about a genotype and we can use
these to compare across our different
119 individuals Within These different
cell types so in each cell type then we
you we also use the genotype information
and make 119 networks in each cell type
what we wanted to do then once we had
all of these networks is ask a sort of
simple first question which is how can
we estimate the genome-wide disruption
of transcription Factor regulation for a
given transcription factor and to do
this
we developed a score that we call the TF
disruption score and it's relatively
straightforward you start with your
Egret Network which has its individual
specific Edge weights here and then we
just subtract the edge weight difference
between the Egret Network for an
individual and the Baseline Network and
we take the absolute value
so for example The Edge weight between
transcription Factor 1 and Gene 1 in the
Egret network is 0.25 that edge weight
in the Baseline network is 2.24 and set
the absolute value of the difference is
1.99 we then repeat this for every Edge
as you can see here for the three edges
I've demonstrated and then the absolute
value of those Edge weights differences
we then combine those we just add them
up to get a total disruption score for a
given transcription factor in a given
individual
so we have this set of scores that we
can use and again these scores are cell
type specific because the Egret Network
and the Baseline Network were both
reconstructed from a particular cell
type
so using these disruption scores we
wanted to ask first since we have
cardiomyocyte data do TFS associated
with coronary artery disease have higher
disruption scores in the cardiomyocyte
networks so we know for example that
these TFS are already associated with
CAD but what we wanted to investigate
was whether or not their targets had
genetic disruptions because the
disruption score does a good job of
asking the question about how are the
targets disrupted not necessarily the TF
itself
so what you're looking at here then is
disruption scores which are on on the
y-axis for each TF associated with CAD
for each individual
and what you can see in the
cardiomyocytes which is abbreviated cm
in the left is that there seems to be
this subset of disruption scores that
are very high in the cardiomyocytes but
not in the ipscs or the lcls and if you
do a t-test to compare the LCL and the
cardiomyocyte disruption scores as
groups you can see that there's a
significant enrichment for the cadtf
disruption scores and cardiomyocytes but
not in the lcl's
we then wanted to ask since we have
these lcl's as well whether or not we
see a cell type specific signal for
Crohn's disease so we again took TFS
that are associated with crohn's disease
and we looked at the disruption scores
for those TFS for each individual in our
three different cell types and what you
can see here quite strikingly is that we
see a strong signal for disruption
scores in the lcls that we don't see in
the cardiomyocytes or the ipscs and
again if you do a t-test comparing the
lcls and the cardiomyocytes you again
see enrichment and lcl's for the Crohn's
disease TS but not in cardiomyocytes
so we think this is a nice example of
how you can use these Egret networks to
identify disease-specific genetic
signals that are also cell type specific
so the next thing we wanted to do then
was dig in a little bit more into this
subset of high scoring TF disruption CAD
TFS in cardiomyocytes and when we looked
into this a little bit more we found
that there was one transcription factor
that was really contributing a lot the
transcription Factor ERG and that
actually the disruption scores were
driven by a variant in The Binding site
for ERG in the regulatory region of the
gene csrp1
and so we wanted ERG of course you know
is already associated with CAD that's
why we were looking at it but we didn't
know anything about csrp1 and so we
wanted to dig in a little bit more we
then went to gtex and looked at the gene
expression for csrp1 across tissues and
what you can see here with the purple
bar is that tibial artery seems to be a
a tissue in which csrp1 is highly
expressed which was reassuring since
we're looking at coronary artery disease
and then we dug in a little bit more
into the literature of csrp1 and found a
number of cardiovascular phenotypes that
were relevant so the csrp1 is associated
with bundling of actin filaments and
cardiovascular development
It's associated with response to
arterial injury
knocked down of csrp1 and zebrafish has
caused cardiac bifida
and there's a frameshift mutation in
csrp1 that has been linked to congenital
cardiac defects
and so all of this together suggests
that csrp1 is an important Gene for
coronary artery disease
our next question was slightly higher
level we wanted to ask how these genetic
variants perturb Network modules so if
there are large groups of weak effect
genes we could affect variants that are
disrupting the regulation of genes can
we identify those and so what we wanted
to do then was ask whether or not these
variants in these modules are perturbed
by an individual's particular variance
and are those groups of genes
functionally related
and so what we can do is again compare
our Baseline network with our Egret
Network so what we do is run a method
called Community detection or modularity
maximization for finding modules in this
Baseline Network and what you want to do
is try to find groups where you have
lots of edges within the group and not
as many between groups for example in
the Baseline Network that I've drawn
here module one has almost all of its
edges between TS and genes within module
one and module two that which I've drawn
over here has most of its edges within
the module and there's only one Edge
that's connecting my two suggesting a
good clustering
and now when I have my Egret Network
these Edge weights have been changed
based on the presence of genetic
variance and their impact and so for
example you can imagine that this Gene
that I've highlighted in Orange here
which was originally uh part of module
two it's Edge weights connecting it to
the TS in module two are now much weaker
than uh than it was in the Baseline
Network and so you might imagine that
actually this Gene this orange Gene
might better be placed in module one and
not in module two because of the change
in the edge weights and so what we'd
like to do then is calculate sort of
this uh change between the Baseline
Network and the Egret Network and the
genes it changes between the modules as
a result and so there's a tool called
alpaca developed by Mega Patty and John
Quackenbush that is specifically
designed to do this and what it does is
it calculates what are called
differential modularity scores for each
gene so what that does is it tells you
sort of how a Gene's modular environment
has changed between the Baseline Network
and the e-grid network
and so what we can do then is take these
differential modularity scores or DM
scores for each gene in each cell type
for a given person and we can ask do
regulatory variants perturb functionally
related genes in an individual and cell
type specific Manner and so to ask this
question what we did is We performed go
enrichment on these DM scores for a
particular individual and then we have
three networks for that that individual
we have the cardiomyocyte the ipsc and
the LCL and so we have a set of DM
scores for each gene in those three
different networks and we ran go
enrichment on the three sets separately
and what you can see is I've highlighted
here the purple is cardiomyocyte the
teal is LCL and the yellow is ipsc and
what we find is a set of cardiomyocyte
specific enrichments a set of LCL
specific enrichments and a set of ipsc
specific enrichments along with a small
subset of enrichments that are present
across multiple cell types and so what
we can find is that these genetic
variants in this individual are
perturbing different processes based on
the cell type we look at
and so we think this is a nice example
of how you can really dig out cell type
and individual specific information
using egret
so
in conclusion
Egret can estimate individual specific
transcription Factor regulatory Networks
these networks reflect genotype specific
and cell type specific regulatory events
the targets of TFS associated with
coronary artery disease and Crohn's
disease shows cell type-specific genetic
disruptions
and variance disrupt functional Gene
modules in these regulatory networks and
if you're interested in more details
about what I've talked about today we
have a preprint up on bioarchive it's
titled predicting genotype specific Gene
regulatory networks Debbie weyhill is
the first author
and with that I'd like to thank my
collaborators and co-authors John and
Marilyn at the Harvard t.h Chan School
of Public Health Debbie who's now at UNC
Chapel Hill and kimby who is a Brigham
and Women's Hospital with me and if
you're interested in working on problems
like this if data integration we're
looking for postdoctoral fellows at the
Channing division of network medicine so
if that's of interest to you please
email me at the website shown here thank
you very much